it's not fun to have your two-ton SUVs
brakes hacked just as your birth in
front of a ditch okay oh that's a hold
on that's what I've learned from Charlie
Miller and Chris valasek a pair of
hackers who have spent the last year
developing a piece of software that can
wirelessly sabotage this 2014 Jeep
Cherokee it hasn't been altered in any
way there are no devices attached to it
but like many thousands of jeeps around
the world it can be remotely hacked over
the internet through a cellular
connection to its entertainment system
that would allow someone to take over
its steering its transmission and even
its brakes to demonstrate that I'm going
to act as today's crash-test dummy and
drive it on the highway here in st.
Louis while Charlie and Chris hijack its
digital systems from Charlie's house
miles away they wouldn't tell me what
they had plans but they assured me that
it wouldn't be anything life-threatening
remember Andy no matter what happens
don't panic it's not the first time I've
driven a car while it's being attacked
by these two hackers but in 2013 they
were in the backseat and their laptops
were wired into the vehicle through a
port in attacking me now they're sending
the same sort of attacks remotely and I
have no idea what they might do he's
going as fast as I've seen yourself so
first we're gonna turn the fan on them
yeah let's turn the fan on TV even
notices
all right all that something just turned
on all the fans and a/c and stuff I
didn't do that the trick started small
oh my god that was a picture of Charlie
and Chris in tracksuits that just
appeared on the dashboard but as I drove
down the interstate things started
getting unpleasant and very loud do it
do it
kill the engine so we're killing the
engine right now I stomped on the gas
but the Jeep slowed to a crawl I turned
on my hazard lights but I was still
stuck in the right lane with no shoulder
to escape onto he's not here
[Music]
the accelerator will work it won't work
your doom we you gotta turn the car off
okay now you should be good to go all
right I'm gonna pull over cuz I have
PTSD Charlie and Chris have only tested
the full range of their attacks on a
Jeep Cherokee but they say that hundreds
of thousands of late-model Chrysler
vehicles may be vulnerable through a
feature called you connect an
internet-connected computer in the
dashboard known as its head unit these
cars had units exposed a particular
service that probably they didn't want
to it lets you do things like query it
for information like the GPS or then are
all sort of things but it also lets you
just run commands you have to first
break into the car remotely over the
cell network and then move laterally if
you want to do things like send canned
messages and those are the messages that
we can use to control things like
steering or the windshield wipers or
braking they plan to release a portion
of their exploit code of the annual
black hat hacker conference next month
they've also alerted Chrysler which is
issuing a security patch but they say a
lot more needs to be done to protect a
new generation of cars
that are increasingly connected to the
Internet and potentially hackable you
guys basically brought brought this car
to a standstill while I was driving on
the highway which I may never forgive
you for that was just like an experiment
what do you think is the worst case
scenario we wanted to point out you know
it's to show that this attack is has
serious consequences for this vehicle
and so we did you know attack you but we
did it in a safe way as we could so we
didn't want you get hurt obviously
that's why we're working is to make sure
that we figure out vulnerabilities
weaknesses get them fixed
we're only two guys with one car right
so you know we can't look at every car
and we want to release this information
because more people like us need to be
focused on this problem after their
stunt on the highway Chris and Charlie
still wanted to show me a couple of
other tricks below a certain speed they
can control the Jeep steering as long as
it's in Reverse poppets locks mess with
the speedometer and of course disable
the brakes okay hold on time
hold on we're gonna be doing some
questioning of the Midwest
New Yorkers don't do that